>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> So welcome back to the afternoon.
Thank you all for coming
back so promptly and it's
with much pleasure I hand over to
Tom Learner to introduce the panel.
Tom Learner, as you all
know, is the Head of Science
at the Getty Conservation Institute
and we always joke about the fact
that we usually have to go out
of the country to see each other
so I will hand over to Tom
to introduce our panel.
>> Thank you, Fenella.
We're missing one speaker,
who are we missing?
Oh, here we go.
I'm going to keep my comments
very, very brief because we ran
over slightly this morning and we
have four fantastic speakers now,
each with 20 minutes so I don't want
to eat anything into that at all.
The bios for each speaker
are in your pack.
This is a pretty impressive panel in
case you haven't figured this out.
I was going to say four
heavyweights from Europe.
I don't want to use that
term in any sort of mean way
but if these were people applying
for the European Council Research
Grants these would be the advanced
level, four very, very established
figures in the European side
of the conservation science so I
believe Michel you're up first.
I'd like to welcome Michel Menu
from the [inaudible] in Paris.
>> I will move closer to you.
So access is the principle aim
of the integrated infrastructure
initiative which is [inaudible]
so as Luca said it's service
given to the community in order
to get access to cutting
edge facilities
and [inaudible] based system
installed inside the Louvre Museum
in Paris, was at the
beginning of this [inaudible]
after the first European project
called [inaudible] was the only
fixed lab facility.
Building the theory of one message
I wanted to emphasize and to point
out after Luca is that
this opportunity we built
with Bruno Brunetti and Antonio
Sgamellotti at the beginning,
it is the development
of this theory of icubes
and LabTech was a networking project
[inaudible] enables us to have
in the future a permanent
infrastructure
and the other thing I
have to emphasize is
that it's [inaudible] what is
difficult to give a definition
for that is heritage science is
natural science follows cultural
heritage and also the data process.
So FIXLAB is inside IPERION now,
given by four facilities and,
two in Hungary, one is in
Debrecen, one is in Budapest and two
in France, Aglae inside
the Louvre Palace
and SOLEIL is Synchrotron
in Paris, near Paris.
I will first of all describe
the four facilities in brief
and give some highlights which have
been achieved during [inaudible].
The purpose of FIXLAB is to
give access to large facilities.
Access is provided by complementary
nondestructive instrumentation
which gives barely not visible
but elemental, structural
and chemical analysis and with
the neutron project I will show
that we are able also
to do some imaging.
First, the first facility in
Hungary is Atomki in Debrecen.
There's access to iron
beam techniques
through Van de Graff
particle accelerator
and Zita [inaudible]
is the coordinator,
the head of this project, the access
for cultural help so in brief,
IBA is a set of different techniques
which are energetic particles
inducing several excitations
of atoms and gives clues in order
to have a total elemental analysis
with [inaudible] which maybe you are
more familiar with x-ray fluoresce,
it's almost the same and for
the light elements [inaudible]
for instance you can use
the nuclear reactions.
You may have also analysis
information in depth
from the first micrometers
from the surface.
In Atomki, they have a nuclear
micro problem that means in vacuum,
they can have a beam spot of
one micrometer in diameter
and can get elemental maps or
a concentration at this stage
but an external microbeam is
also available with about 20,
30 micrometers in diameter because
you have a spread of diffusion
of the beam and you may analyze
directly the object without putting
in vacuum, without any preparation.
That's the team, Zika is here
and we know the IPERION community
and know her and also
her colleagues here.
The second facility is Budapest
Neutron Center associated
with the Wigner Center and it's
based on the nuclear neutron reactor
and gives several techniques
I will show now.
The neutrons are used
for elemental analysis.
You may get this kind of analysis.
You can also achieve structural
studies with neutron defraction
or small angle neutron
scattering and also
with the neutrons it's
used for imaging.
This example is given for an
Egyptian jar and the imaging
with neutrons of this jar
was most interesting in order
to understand what the
content of the jar was.
That's the team.
The head of the project
is [inaudible],
the BND welcome desk is [inaudible]
and also [inaudible] is the
coordinator of the access to BNC.
The third facility is SOLEIL, it's a
synchrotron of the third generation
which has been implemented
a few years ago south
of Paris in Gif-sur-Yvette.
Among 20 beam lights, about
11 beamlines can be used
for [inaudible].
These are the applications
you may get.
Frederique [inaudible] is
the leader for IPERION,
the task leader for SOLEIL.
You may have tomography
beamlines at SOLEIL
with ANATOMIX, PSICHE, and PUMA.
I will come back to PUMA
a little bit later on
and give some information
with if you increase the resolution
you decrease the energy and so on.
You have also microbeam
lines at SOLEIL.
You have five beam
lines which can be used
for cultural heritage purposes.
What is also said is that this
project is enhanced not only
on cultural heritage
artifacts per se but also
with paleontological artifacts.
PUMA is the beamline which is
photons utilizes materiaux anciens,
it's an acronym and it has been
optimized for ancient materials
so that means cultural and
paleontological materials
and 60 percent of the beamtime will
be allocated for ancient materials
so the description of PUMA and this
beamline, which develops ongoing
at the moment will be open
in about a year from now.
That's the team SOLEIL, more
than 300 people so it's headed
by [inaudible] and
[inaudible] is somewhere here.
He's barely visible
but Frederick is here.
AGLAE in my laboratory and a long
time ago I installed this machine
and at the moment it's stopped
for renewing and for new,
to be completely transformed
and to be completely automatized
to give better service to the people
and so it's a tandem accelerator.
It's an American tandem accelerator
from Middleton Wisconsin Medicine
and this is the only accelerator
which is 100 percent
devoted to cultural heritage.
Claire [inaudible] who is here,
is now the leader of the group
with three other engineers
[inaudible].
So now, for the recent
application and some highlights.
The first highlight was sent
to me by Atomki and by Zita.
They analyzed glass weights in order
to answer to detailed composition
of this glass weights
of the [inaudible].
Identification of the traces and the
other colors and in order to look
at the technology and
at the same time,
the same Portuguese team sent
medieval glass from a site in Italy
and here are the samples
which are embedded in resin
and the questions are almost the
same composition characterization
and also the understanding of
the alteration of the glass.
Another highlight has been given
to me by the Budapest Nation Center
and they analyzed by Daniella
DeMartino [assumed spelling] some
artifacts from the Milano Cathedral
and they analyzed and wanted
to understand the deterioration
of [inaudible]
which strengthens the
architecture of the cathedral.
You have to trust me about
it because that's deep into,
it's not bright enough but here
you have cracks which are visible
by the naked eye but others are
not invisible and has been revealed
to light with the neutron tomography
and even cracks considerably weaken
the strength of the materials
and it was interesting for
the architects in order
to restore the cathedral.
Another example briefly
concerns this processional cross
with the same applicant
Daniella DeMartino,
from an abbey in Italy close
to Milano and the results
of that was used not
only gamma activation
but also some XRF x-ray
fluorescence and other techniques.
It's a silver cross which is gilded
and they will be able to confirm
through the presence of
mercury the amalgam technique.
The last highlight I
wanted to present is one
which has been achieved
in my laboratory,
the Medieval Kashi project.
It's a lustered ceramics from Iran
and this map shows the invention
of the lustered ceramics in
Mesopotamia in the eighth century
of the Christ and this
technique spread all
over the Mediterranean
basin to arrive
in Italy during the renaissance
period so Egypt, Madrid, Spain,
and this technique
continued at the same time.
This object is so valuable but
like this, you are not allowed
to sample them and so ion beam
techniques are very interesting
in order to show how
the stratification
of the lustre has been
achieved during this time
and so we have this
technique called [inaudible]
by scattering spectrometry
and through processing the spectra
you may analyze the different
thickness of the lustre proper which
is small metallic nano particles
which are embedded inside the glaze
of the ceramics and processing that,
you may achieve the thickness of
the coating of nano particles,
the thickness of the glaze,
and how deep are these nano
particles embedded inside the glaze.
And so, you can achieve through that
this stratography and the glaze,
the lustre, the glaze
again, and the ceramic body.
So thank you for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Michel.
We'll get through the
four presentations
and then there will be a Q&A
answer session at the end.
Our second speaker will be
speaking about the second
of the three services
under IPERION's CH dealing
with transnational
access so you just heard
about the FIXLAB work package.
Antonio Sgamellotti,
Professor Emeritus
from Universita di
Perugia will now talk us
through the MOLAB work package
looking at mobile laboratories.
>> Thank you very much so I will
speak about the mobile laboratory
and archives in IPERION CH and
we start with the archives.
Archives were introduced in the
last project in CHARISMA [phonetic]
and it was a very successful
platform.
It's the access to the
archive or European museum
in cultural heritage institution.
We started with six institutions,
The National Gallery in London,
the Opificio delle
Pietre Dure in Florence,
the Centre de Recherche et
de Restauration in Paris,
the British Museum in London, the
Museo Nacional del Prado in Madrid
and the Cultural Heritage
Agency of the Netherlands.
In IPERION, there was an increase of
the institution giving the service.
We now have the Instituto
del Cultural de Madrid,
the Centre for Art Technological
Studies and Conservation
of Copenhagen, the
Rathgen Museum in Berlin
and the Instituut Royaal du
Patrimoine artistique in Brussel.
This is a physical assess,
it's not a visual assess.
The archive contains
a lot of documentation
but not just documentation, also
samples, also cross sections and so
on and so forth and those
are in different sizes,
in different nations so
some examples for instance,
in Opificio della Pietre
Dure you get a lot
of information concerning Rafael
data, cross sections refractography.
In the British museum you get
information about the technique
of old statue as in ancient times
and then you get cross section,
then you have a spectra, then you
have map so a lot of documentation
which can be very, very useful.
Useful to whom?
To each other, you are always
the chairperson [laughter].
Useful to whom?
To researchers, that they want to
collect information for instance
on paintings, on the material,
colors, support, stratigraphy
and composition of grounds.
Art historians or archaeologists
what want to carry
on provenance studies
on different techniques,
conservators and scientists.
It's not working properly
but it doesn't matter,
there were some examples
for instance one researcher
from Czechoslovakia went to
the Opificio della Pietre Dure
to study the ground of
the 16th century painting
and there was a lot of information.
This is a typical case.
This is the [inaudible]
the famous [inaudible].
It's a tryptic but the three parts
are in three different museums
in Florence in [inaudible], in
the National Gallery in London
and the other one is in
Louvre, of course [laughter].
I always say [inaudible].
This was a case of a researcher on
this triptych and the best way was
to go to the archives of these three
important institutions where a lot
of information is present.
In this you'll see some of the
people working in Madrid, in London,
and in Paris in a very
relaxed atmosphere
and also the environment
is very pleasant also.
Now let's go to the mobile
laboratory which together
with the FIXLAB was the
first infrastructure
in the European project [inaudible]
just these two infrastructures
and then you see things are going
to increase according to the needs
of the cultural heritage community.
In the previous CHARISMA,
we had just two providers
[inaudible] Perugia
and the Florence CNR and then
the Universita di Perugia
and very recently also
a regional laboratory
in [inaudible] joined
to this joint project.
And then the CNRS in Paris,
these were the two
provides in the previous.
Now we have some more providers,
FORTH Foundation for Research
and Technology in Hellas, Heraklion,
The Nicolaus Copernicus University
in Torun in Poland and the
Aachen University in Germany.
Which are the users?
The user conservator-restorers,
who carry out research
on innovative methods in
restoration and preservation just
to make an example,
conservation scientists who want
to integrate their
measurements by micro-sampling
with non-invasive investigations
and of course art historians
and archaeologists who want to study
execution techniques in painting,
ceramics, sculpture
and a lot of art works.
A few examples, this is a study
that was done by the MOLAB
and the title was [inaudible]
studies on the last judgment,
which is [inaudible] and is in
the [inaudible] museum in Poland.
What was the aim of the project?
It was to study changes in
design, details in the composition,
stages of under-drawing, different
characters of paint layers in order
to identify material,
technique, and also the artist
because probably it's not
just [inaudible] is present
in these big paintings and
the [inaudible] of the Academy
of Fine Arts in [inaudible].
I just want to point upon an
important which is in accord
to the European rules
[inaudible] in the data,
the intellectual properties
of the results according
to the European rules
belong to the users.
They do not belong to the MOLAB
operators but to the users.
Very often at the end
there is a collaboration
and very often there is
a common publication.
That was a very, in a way,
long project because three MOLAB
facilities were involved, CNR,
the Universita di Perugia and the
CNRS for 15 days of in situ access.
Usually the intervention
lasts five days
and you spend a lot
of time traveling.
I want to say that in the last
12 years, we have been traveling
for more than 200,000 kilometers
in Euro which is quite a lot.
Fifteen days, because there were
three different MOLAB facilities
operating with 10 MOLAB
operatos, four users,
and sis non-invasive instruments.
Which are here, XRF, mid and near
infrared, UV visible spectroscopy,
XRD, multi-spectral scanning.
This is the MOLAB working.
Fortunately, there were three
separate parts of the tryptic
so they were able to
work at the same time
on the three different parts
and we got a lot of results.
I just want to show some of them.
For instance, using FTIR
and also XRD and I want
to stress the importance
to use different techniques
to get some useful results.
In the gem of St. Michael's
there is pure lazurite while
in the blue dress of Mary
there is lazurite and lazurite
with little amount of diopside and
azurite in the [inaudible] while
in the reflection of the blue dress
from this piece there is azurite.
The infrared didn't have
good results on this case
but we were able to get interesting
results using the refractions.
For instance, we were able to
detect the lead tin yellow type I,
the cinnabar, the [inaudible]
hydrocerussite and cerussite
and also using UV visible
[inaudible].
Very, very interesting were
the results with the reflector.
Some results were already known this
is for instance the visible light
and this is the x-ray ready
made by the user in Warsaw
and also there was some
refractograpy made but look
at the difference in how you can see
the details using the refractography
of the [inaudible] CNR in Florence.
You can see easily all
the details and according
to these results it's
probably the [inaudible].
Research is still in
progress from this one.
All this results were reported, one
of the chapters of Science and Art,
the Painted Surface by the Royal
Society of London, of which I am one
of the [inaudible] together
with my colleague [inaudible].
And as you can see, this
is a joint publication
between the user [inaudible] and
the MOLAB operator [inaudible].
Passing from the previous CHARISMA
to the [inaudible] there was
also an increase of technique.
We already had point
chemical analysis
but we include more other techniques
like multi/hyper spectral imaging
and the visible near
and far infrared
and also x-ray fluorescence
scanning including 3D surface
and volume image which
were implemented
in the joint research activity
of the previous project.
There is a strong connection
between the joint research activity
which has the mission to improve
the facilities in the MOLAB
so they implement new
instrumentation
and once they were tested and
they are well functioning,
they became part of the MOLAB
so there is just a few
examples [inaudible].
You see, this is a
collaboration with the [inaudible].
This painting of the 15th century
was completely black probably due
to fire in the chapel and it was
almost impossible to read but look
through mapping, the different
elements lead, copper, alum,
gold and iron, you can see easily
and so you can be a good guy
in the restoration process.
Spectral imaging, this is some
of the work that University
of Perugia did in which
it was possible apart
from the lead [inaudible] to
detect some important pigments
like [inaudible] in red,
emerald green which is in green
and aquamarine, which is in blue.
Then, from the fourth digital
[inaudible] it was used to reveal
in situ detachments,
cracks and other defects.
The purpose was the examination
of 19th century ceiling
to assess detachment and
cracks through the defect map,
risk map comparison
with conservators maps.
This is a mobile single site
[inaudible] provided by [inaudible]
and you can get information
about the depth profiling
of hydrogen containing
materials in stone,
mortar, paintings and so forth.
[Inaudible] tomography provided
by Torun in Poland for examination
of layered structures in easel
paintings and this is a project
in collaboration with the
Opificio della Pietre Dure
under Leonardo and that's all.
The next call is coming
soon the 15th of February.
Usually there are two calls which
are 15th of September and 15th
of February so if you
are interested,
the call is almost
ready to be announced.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Antonio, and I
know there'll be some questions
about submitting samples
and projects
for these things when we got to Q&A.
Our third speaker is Jorgen Wadum,
who seems to be Director of many,
many places in Copenhagen but the
quickest way is perhaps to talk
about the new Center for
Art Technological Studies
and Conservation called CATS,
and Jorgen is going to be talking
about the corporation networking
side of IPERION CH so Jorgen.
>> Thank you very much.
Well, you introduced the whole
gang up here as being very old
and mature consortium and true
you are of course however, CATS,
which is a small national research
infrastructure comprising the
National Museum of Denmark,
the National Gallery of Denmark
with which I'm working, and
the training school facilities
at the Royal Academy of Fine
Arts Training for Conservators,
we only joined this group of
excellent researchers very recently
when IPERION was established,
after all the other preparatory
research infrastructures
so we are entirely new in this but
never the less, we have been tasked
with the task of facilitating
a corporation
and networking internally
within IPERION and also to reach
out to users and users
outside IPERION in order
to promote European cultural
heritage science and we are
of course, as you can see on the
slide, and which you will have
on the website of this
institute afterwards,
we wanted to foster
cooperation and action
with heritage science communities,
all users of the transnational
access points
that we just heard about,
and potential scientific
industrial partners.
We also want to address more widely
the multidisciplinary researchers
and stakeholder's concerns with
this research area including both
conservators but also curators,
historians, archaeologists
and whoever is working with
cultural heritage optics also
within as I said, industry
or institutions or small
and medium sized enterprises.
The specific objectives are
many and you can see them here.
It's focused on high level
advocacy of the expert meetings,
we want to make hands on workshops,
I'm going to mention a few
in a moment, seminars, and
to disseminate this as widely
as possible and hopefully to
engage as many of you as possible
in the audiences when they
are open for everybody
but we also organize
more internal workshops
where it is the IPERION
partners that collaborate
with maybe a few stakeholders that
we take in to be operating not
within a vacuum but within still
the surrounding environment.
We also want to carry out a number
of best practices and protocols
to develop this to publish them
for all of you and to carry
out foresight studies
as you can see in order
to identify future
research priorities,
what we heard about earlier today
and opportunities for
innovation in this.
You can see the acronyms CATS,
and CNR, and ND and [inaudible],
they are the institutions
that are in charge
of these individual projects
within work packets nine.
What we are doing in CATS
is trying to take care
of the knowledge exchange
activities,
establishing these best practice
protocols together with the CNR
so Susanna Bracci, who is not
here and with Marika Spring,
representing the National
Gallery we worked
on these foresight studies I
just mentioned and Erik Buelinckx
from KIK-IRPA will work on
creating digital data management
and procedures for this.
This will start later on in the
project and we do not have much
to share on this from my
side at this very moment.
We have a lot of deliverables
that we want to share
that will be visible on our website
and eventually published also
on other media, reports and surveys,
analytical data expectations,
we have recommendations of best
practice etc. We have a whole range
of deliverables that you can see on
the IPERION home page and they go.
We are supposed to have a very
busy four years of research
and presentations as you can see.
Well, some of these activities
have taken place of course.
We have had an International
Conference on Glazed Ceramics
in Architectural Heritage which was
the first conference we organized
within the current IPERION network
and the aim of this conference was
to discuss [inaudible] and other
architectural glaze ceramics
of historic interest
manufactured and applied anywhere
that they may have been, their
characteristics, the decay,
and the conservation of
these kinds of objects.
It was a conference that
was attended by 81 delegates
from a lot of different countries.
Well, that was the top one.
The second one was
more internal workshop
with just a few stakeholders
from outside the
conservation/restoration community
of the Netherlands, Cleaning of
Paintings and Protection of Metals.
It was a workshop organized by
[inaudible] from the [inaudible]
in Amsterdam in collaboration also
with a joint project initiative
research project called CMOP
which is an abbreviation of
Cleaning of Modern Oil Paints,
which is a consortium between the
University of Amsterdam, the Tate,
the Getty, and a number of
other partners that work
on identifying safe cleaning
of modern oil paints.
Again, there's a relationship
with [inaudible],
which is another project
running until 2018 actually.
It is [inaudible] who is
sitting here in the auditorium
who is the project leader of
this project about the cleaning
of modern oil paints but
the workshop there was more
of internal character
defining what kind of practice
and projects would be most relevant.
Another project was Investigating
Heritage Material with Safer Ion
and Photon Beam Experiments.
It took place as a collaboration
between the [inaudible] in Paris
and the meeting was also there,
attended by a huge
crowd 40 participants
and 30 guests from aound the world.
Eighteen countries were represented
and the program included a part
from [inaudible] presenting also
recent advances, also round tables,
[inaudible] and open sessions for
the people attending this meeting.
In Copenhagen, organized in
collaboration between the Prado
and the National Gallery in London,
CATS hosted a workshop called
Preparation for Painting, Grounds
and Primings in European
Paintings 1500 to 1800,
and this was a workshop, which
is operating very closely
with workshop eight, which is led
by Joe Padfield and Marika Spring
from the National Gallery.
You will hear more about this
from Joe in a while, I'm sure.
quantities of data like
cross-sections that we have heard
about in the previous
speaker will lie in archives
and be accessible via arts lab
but if we could digitize them
and put them online, we could
share them with the world
and you could share
yours with us probably.
So, the idea is to create a
Europe-wide scale collaborative
development between
conservation science
and digital documentation
specialists to more efficient access
to cross-sectional data,
improved data comparability
across the consortium.
You may imagine that photographs
are cross-sections made in one lab
with one set of filters
are difficult to compare
with cross sections of the same
artist materials in another lab
with a different set of filters,
although we call them the same type
of either UV or natural
light, whatever.
We hope to come up with
suggestions for this over the course
of the IPERION research area.
We also had a conference where we
were studying European Visual Arts
1800 to 1850, hosted
by CATS in Copenhagen
and this was a technical art
history conference because we tried
to bridge conservation science
to the hardcore humanities art
historians and they are not,
some art historians fall asleep when
they see cross section number three
and scientists may do the same
when they see I don't know how
many images of something that they,
but we want to bridge this and
make questions and maybe try to see
if what we call technical art
history is actually not just art
history as it was in the past
with an added scientific value
of the analytical data that science
can produce for the understanding
of cultural heritage
objects in general.
So we're studying this over two
days and we have participants also
from the US in this conference
and then we've just had our
first doctoral summer school,
advanced characterization of
techniques, diagnostic tools,
evaluation of methods
in heritage science.
It took place in Madrid and was
organized by the IPERION in Spain.
This doctoral summer school
will provide advanced lectures
on analytical and diagnostic
tools for students
and the lectures were
including up to date development
in conservation materials
and recent advances
of all the aspects you would need
to be put in front of in order to go
out and work in our sector and there
were 30 students attending this
summer school, also from
14 different countries
within the European community.
Forthcoming meetings Intangibility
Matters is an international
conference that the LNEC in Lisbon
is organizing in May '17, two days,
which will look at the immaterial
sides of tangible cultural heritage
and discuss all sorts of
aspects related to the values
and reflections, etc. Keep an
eye out for the announcements
for this conference, I bet it's
going to be very interesting
for those working with
intangible matters.
There will also be a
joint project initiative,
so next conference taking place
two days after in Beja in June,
also working in that
same direction and trying
to investigate objects
of that nature.
The ion bean photon workshop was
so popular that the members wanted
to have another one so another one
also is popping up in '17 in June.
It will be taking place in
Amsterdam and organized by the ICN
in collaboration with NICAS and
other partners so keep an eye
out for that for those
of you who are interested
in these kind of workshops.
And then finally, there will be
an international conference called
Tempera between 1850 and 1950,
a painting technique at the dawn
of modernity which will be held
at the Doerner Institute in Munich
and it has to do with
in recent years a new
and profound attempt was made to
explore the complex research field
of tempera painting in the
19th and 20th century which has
until now only been very
briefly discussed in literature.
We want to organize here a two
day program which also will look
at the sources of the
studio practice, materiality
and of course the art
historical aspects
of why is tempera painting having
a revival at that particular moment
and how can that assist us in
understanding you could say,
the bigger picture of the moment,
the interaction of technology
and aesthetics in painting
of that particular period.
There will soon here in December
be a call for contributions
to this conference so keep
an eye out for this too.
Well, drawing into other
work packages then the one
that CATS is particularly in
charge of is a work package her
on establishing cross disciplinary
best practices and protocols.
Susanna Bracci had
been making a survey
and had asked colleagues primarily
in the European community to reflect
on best practices within analysis
and treatment of a variety
of objects and materials that we
encounter in our cultural heritage
at [inaudible] and this report
will be coming out pretty soon
and will be the basis for
further research within IPERION
such as the foresight studies
and best practices and protocols
but mainly the foresight studies
and as I'm mentioning here,
which is aiming at exploring
the idea within IPERION not
to replicate what's
already been done elsewhere
in the development
heritage science strategies
but to consider the question
from the point of view
of developing strategies
that support the research
infrastructures examining what
instruments and tools
might be needed
to address the research priorities
being identified by the group
and where and how these are
needed to fill the gaps.
This work is also ongoing
and we have research results
coming out as they emerge.
There will also be a course
planned in November '17 in London
and combined with the second
user meeting taking advantage
of the presence of an audience
of stakeholders in London.
The date has been chosen
to immediately precede another
planned IPERION workshop activity,
a colloquium on 3D imaging to
be held at the British Museum
on the 10th of November,
2017 so you're well ahead
and can start saving up
for the travels and we hope
that you'll draw a lot of
participants from also this country.
Leading up to the speakers of
tomorrow also, we have a work packet
or task in the work packet
networking and external cooperation
on heritage digital data management
exploitation use and reuse.
It's a very long title for this and
it is Erik Buelinckx from KIK-IRPA
in Brussels who is coordinating
this and I should say it's earlier,
the project is beginning to form
itself now and in the beginning
of '17, a first survey will be
carried out within this network
to identify and gather all relevant
information regarding the task.
The main point of interest will be
to define a broader
network also outside IPERION
and to see how the
questions will be geared there
to involve DARIAH-ERIC
and other stakeholders.
Sharing data is something
that some fields
in the humanities are not
very good at I daresay.
Others are very good at them.
I believe that conservation science
and conservators are
sharing quite a lot however,
there are still elements
within research data
that are not being shared.
Let me just mention one,
dendrochronological data.
That is kept very strict
to the people who do this.
Maybe we should discuss how that
could change for the benefit
of the entire field and the
cultural heritage objects,
where you can combine of
course, knowledge about climate,
heritage objects, either
electronics, paintings, sculptures,
archaeological wood and everything
comes together there and can be
of huge importance for the field.
So having said all this and having
showed you two slides very quickly
here that you haven't
got time to read,
I think I will simply just
say thank you and keep
up for the slides you will
get, and I hope that many
of you will join the
network activities
that we organized within IPERION.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Jorgen and thank you
actually for all three speakers
so far for being very punctual
and in fact a little bit early.
We're catching some time
up so no pressure Georgios.
You have to no let us down.
Our final speaker,
Georgios Karagiannis.
He's behind me right, yes,
the Scientific Internal Head
from the Diagnosis Centre
of the Ormylia Foundation
in northern Greece and he'll
be talking about the knowledge
and innovation technology transfer
research going on in IPERION CH.
>> Thank you very much
for being here.
I'm going to talk about knowledge
innovation and technology transfer
in IPERION project, which is a
rather difficult lecture actually.
Since our cultural heritage is
our common memory and knowledge
as human beings, one of the main
concerns should be the cultivation
of the current and next generations.
We do believe that and
so UNESCO guidelines
and documents are indeed fostering
consciousness of our culture
through the cultivation of the
current and the next generations.
All this is in accordance
with UNESCO.
Also, the technological
development and the living data
of the technological development
so our endeavor should
also focus the cultivaion
of the next generation towards
the cultivated use of technology.
I would say that technology and
culture are things that go together
but technology, as you know, is a
Greek word related to the techni
which is art and which is also the
craft creation actually and the term
of logos which is actually
our wisdom finally,
and finally our spiritual heritage.
IPERION project is not far
away from this main idea
and this main target I would say,
because we are using IPERION
various different kind of radiations
and state of the art prototypes in
order actually to make endoscopy
of an object and search the
deepest information of these
and the deepest hidden
beauty of the art objects
which is actually providing
us the possibility
to create new cultural richness.
This is very important
because the self-consciousness
that we are achieving using the
results of the analysis is more
or less an exercise about
our self-consciousness,
according to Socrates,
which means [inaudible]
and this is a great
power actually in order
to create a new heritage
and a new art.
Well, within this vision I would
say that now as you have seen
in the morning and
from other presenters,
we have accumulated knowledge
within this series of projects
which actually LabsTech was
initiated in some initial discussion
of [inaudible] based on a
previous existing network.
Again, something started
again from Greece here
and of course this accumulated
knowledge is enriched using these
access actions and by acces actions
we are gaining advanced knowledge
because we are not
providing our analysis only,
but we are gaining much
knowledge from the users.
Michel and Antonio talked
about these actions before.
I would say that the knowledge and
the innovation that we are gaining
within these projects and actually
in IPERION project is mainly based
on transnational access and
the joint research activities
that are main pillars
of the project.
I would say that now, Professor
Antonio Sgamellotti we are
in the position to say that
we have a new heritage.
It's not only the heritage of
the data that we have acquired
from cultural heritage objects
but it's also the creators
of the technology platform
that we have
and this technological platform
provides us the possibility o have
this osmosis between the communities
of the technology provides,
the chemistry, physics, and
engineers with art historians
and the conservators and this is
now made practice so I would name
that this is a blessing and
finally a blossom of a new science.
This is my dimension
about heritage science
and of course the incarnation
of innovation
in IPERION project is mainly based
on the diagnostic instruments
which we are going to talk
tomorrow about, diagnostic methods,
and the data that we are producing.
These are the three actions that
you have been presented before.
So what are we offering?
We are in the position to
make analysis of various kinds
of objects, paintings,
byzantine icons, metallic objects
or various metallic materials,
ceramics, wall paintings,
glass objects and using these
techniques like optical tomography,
non-radiating imaging, spectroscopic
mapping imaging or [inaudible],
acoustic microscopy new techniques,
nuclear magnetic resonance,
[inaudible] imaging, we are
providing to the end user
in the community two dimensional
mapping images of the materials
or [inaudible] and
finally combining them
with tomographic information
we are edging to having
by the coupling points
of the analytical points
and the imaging methods,
high resolution
and fidelity 3D tomographic
information
with all the qualitative
information embedded on them.
So this finally provides
us the possibility
to support the vivid navigation of
the adventure of the art objects
in time and in space so we
can navigate in the beauty
of these objects while
the time passes
in the space that they were found.
I had a mind to give some paradigms
which will be presented better
tomorrow in my presentation,
just to be coherent with
the previous speakers,
in order to have a more vivid
information about the kind
of information that we received.
Sorry, we can go here next.
Of course, this is, I took from our
colleague Hilda some [inaudible]
on some cases.
The kind of [inaudible] that we
have is by infrared refractor
for instance, the art
drawings beyond the visible
so we have information
about what happens in the
under layers of the object.
And of course, in this case for
instance we can reveal foils
on the gold leave in specific
areas of the art objects.
And then, using Tera-Hertz
for instance imaging we
have better penetration
than the infrared imaging,
revealing the hidden gold
in specific art objects.
Mapping images as Antonio
had presented before,
we have [inaudible] with
the materials on it as well
as using synchrotron based
x-ray methods, we have evidence
of the degradation on the
material on the surfaces
as in the other layers and
then we have mapping images
and also hyperspectral imaging we
can observe better the distribution
of the [inaudible] of the object.
And finally, tomography
is [inaudible] here
with which we can navigate the depth
of the information the object
revealing the pathology
of the application with various
varnishes in the pigments in depth.
Since philosophy means Praxis, in
work package 11 of IPERION project,
we are trying finally to transfer
this innovation and recommendation
about art objects to
the industry and mainly
to small medium enterprises
and vice versa, I'm not sure.
The osmosis between research
community and industry
or mainly SMEs will be stressed
targeting to the creation
of novel products and
spin off companies.
These guidelines of European
Commission [inaudible]
and I do believe the market
needs such kinds of actions
but this action is
multidirectional interaction,
I would say because this processes
that are needed to be done in order
to reach such a target are
unidirectional and are characterized
by the interactions in order to try
to match the supply with the demand
so we have to see what is a demand
and what is a market behind this
and in this case there
are many factors actually.
Mainly, the researchers/us which
have to place their ideas in order
to chase for new funding and then
the other side we also have the
institutions where they
have to adapt themselves
to new global European and
national research policies and what
about the social impact
in assessment?
We have to have a turnover to
the society about the findings
that we were gaining and give
this knowledge to the society back
and then the companies are the other
actors in private sector which need,
indeed in the planet the companies
need new ideas and new opportunities
in order to overcome recession.
And finally, the government,
the decision makers who want
to assess their investment in
order to account for their policies
and here we have to fight
towards the governments in order
to take care of cultural heritage.
And the various actors of
course imply various needs,
which much be coordinated
an then main channels
for research results transfer
up to now have been the traditional
patents databases usually
in the patent offices Of course,
these kinds of channels in order
to disseminate your knowledge,
the patents are restricted
and they are not so well
accessible via the web technologies.
Therefore, we thought that new
instruments are needed in order
to transmit the knowledge and
social media is a kind of tool
in order to do this work.
Because of their features, scholarly
community has increasingly employed
social medial in order to
communicate their results
in a better and faster way
and furthermore studies
about new metrics based on
social media are being developed.
What are the existing tools?
The existing tools of social media
are like LinkedIn or Academia,
ResearchGate, okay
Facebook, I don't believe that
but in any case this
is also social media.
This situation is so the power
of social media is constantly
increasing, indeed it is increasing
and the new generations
are using them.
For this reason, we thought that
the ad hoc social media focused
on innovation and technology
transfer could increase the
communication between various
actors that I presented you before
and the whole innovation system.
So, in order to maximize
the technology transfer
within the IPERION project, based
on common interests between industry
and research area, we
are looking forward
to win to win collaborations.
A new tool, we decided to develop
a new tool which is named SpinBook
which was developed by IRCrES and
finally was adapted in collaboration
with the ORMYLIA Foundation
for the needs
of work packet 11 of
the IPERION project.
While I'm presenting you first
this tool that is placed now
into operation and from now
on we will start using this.
SpinBook considers all
types of actors involved
in the innovation process
from researches to companies,
public administration, investors,
intermediaries enterprises.
These are the stakeholders of this.
We expect that SpinBook will
be used by various actors.
Political decision makers and
universities should also use this
so as far as one can
enter to the system
to build a profile identifying
himself as a researcher
or enterprise or broker, or
founder, or public administration.
You make a login and you
make a profile there.
Also, we expect that
industrial sector should be able
to access the selected hi-tech
information in order to assess
in a reliable way the
economic potential of the range
of available skills and to
have the chance to acquire it
within a short space of time.
The industrial sector is there.
I can skip this, so then in
SpinBook, we have the possibility
to have a direct communication among
these profiles so SpinBook aims
to set up a social room
between all the actors
for the innovation process giving
them a sustainable visibility
and also giving a boost
to new ideas and projects.
We have concrete control of
the data and careful validation
so when you are filling your
profile you are filling some basic
information related to the
research and to the institution
in order to identify them.
This can be done in some minutes
and then this is a real-time
system informed real-time
so the various factors among
them can start communicating
and exchanging ideas
but the core objective
of SpinBook its powerful search
engine inside, with the capability
to retrieve information
extended to any type of document
that is loaded into the system.
You can search about what kind of
technology you can find with this.
And then, this is done by
another form and that's the form
where the researcher
or enterprise can enter
and fill what is the expectation
or what is the innovation
and what is the pattern
that had developed.
It can also add some multimedia
files there like documents, videos,
whatever related to the
pattern that he has done
so we are knowing exactly
who does what and where.
And then, I would say that the
sole prerogative of SpinBook is
that it can also provide
the summary sheet
in which the researchers
decided to specify
in more detail the applicative
potentialities of their results.
Such information, for obvious
reasons are confidential
and have been collected in a
special section of SpinBook
and appear locked to
the consultation.
To access the full reading of this
tab, users can get in touch directly
with the researcher
via a private message.
In this case, the software foresees
that they want [inaudible] gives
access to the one that asked for it
and then this is accessible
to other users
and then the collaboration
can start the discussion.
In conclusion, we need to
provide the tools in order
to give our technology to the
ones that are interested for this
and we are provided on the
other side this heavy heritage
that I have described to you before.
The acquisitions of new technologies
are of paramount importance
for the European SMEs which usually
can only invest limited resources
in the innovation.
Moreover, it's crucial to
promote strong interactions
between public research and the
industry through related figures
as investors and intermediaries.
Therefore, SpinBook's main
result will have to concretize
into a real European knowledge
community in the field
of cultural heritages like a
place of meeting and sharing
between the main groups involved,
as well as a progressive space
of aggregation of any stakeholders
working in the process of production
and utilization of innovation.
SpinBook is already published and
now you can see the link there
and join it, and not we will
start filling it with companies
and patents mainly starting from
the users of the IPERION project
and then we will see how it
will go, so thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> I'm going to stand
here and you can share,
there's enough microphones
now I think and I think right
in saying these microphones get
picked up by the camera but not
to the audience so it's not a
bad room actually for projecting.
We have about 10 minutes assigned
to questions and hopefully answers.
Does anybody want to kick it off
with a question for
any of our speakers?
And if not, I'm going
to get us going.
>> I have one, sir.
>> You have a question?
>> Yes.
>> Go for it.
>> This is technical but I wanted
to ask, what are the dimensions
of the various layers, if you know?
>> Of the various-
>> Layers.
>> Of the various layers yes,
they are about micrometer layers.
The layer of embedded nanoparticles
is about 200 nanometers in thickness
and thanks to the efficiency of
the [inaudible] spectrometry,
we are able to measure
exactly with certainty
of course, these different layers.
>> Can I just ask some general
questions to Michel and to Antonio
about the three labs, so
MOLAB, [inaudible] and FIXLAB,
just can you talk a little
bit about the process
of how decisions are made about who
gets access to which instrumention?
Michel, do you want to
start off with the FIXLAB?
>> My laboratory gives access to the
three MOLAB, [inaudible] and FIXLAB
and each, to get access to that,
you have to fill a proposal
and as Antonio has mentioned
they are called twice a year
and these proposals are
evaluated by peer review panels,
one for each access and if accepted
the applicant will enter in contact
with the access provider and
they will have the possibility
to find a date where the MOLAB
can go to the work of art,
when the applicant can come to the
archives in the different centers
or when the applicant can come with
his objects, with his artifacts
to be analyzed either in
Hungary or in France for FIXLAB.
>> There is a panel for the
examination of the peer review.
This is usually three people
and nobody from the providers
of the service is part of the panel,
[inaudible] everything
is then [inaudible].
MOLAB is the only one
infrastructure,
which goes the other way around.
The community is paying for
the operators, not for the use
and that was very difficult.
I was on the committee in
the beginning and they say
but we do not have the forms, we
have the forms to pay the users,
not the operators and then the
second big question was how much
does it cost for MOLAB to be
a European infrastructure.
Because usually, the infrastructure
are very, very expensive [inaudible]
and hard to convince
but they were convinced
that [inaudible] was
important but the software
for the professionals were unique
and that made the infrastructure
unique.
>> It's probably different
for each of the three services
but do you think the amount of time
or funding allocated is about right?
Are we getting the right
amount of applications
to projects being accepted or is it
too competitive or is it too easy?
How is it sort of working out?
>> The applications are
helped by an access board.
That means if they wish
to write a proposal,
if they want they can enter in
contact with the access board
and they will have counsel
from the access board
in order to reach the exact time.
>> There is [inaudible]
facilitated proposal but in terms
of your questions, I would say
that there [inaudible] very
few proposals [inaudible].
>> Jorgen, I have a
question for you as well.
I'm always intrigued with these
projects that try to pull together,
we call it best practice or
whatever it is where you're trying
to get different groups who
probably have very established ways
of working and you're trying
to get them all to kind
of adopt one methodology.
Is it too soon to say in practice
the ease of that happening or not?
Do you find people open to that
seeing a benefit or people kind
of dig their heels in and
say my way's the best?
>> I think you already
answered it [laughter].
>> It is difficult to find
common grounds in some places
and convince each other that
that's the way to do it.
Sharing is also a difficult issue
in this, how much do you share
and how well do you do it?
Talking about this, the founder of
the [inaudible] in the 19th century,
when he developed a good yeast he
went out in Europe and offered it
to all of the other
breweries in Europe
so we could have a good competition
on who could make the best
beer based on the same formula
and that is a very
generous way of doing it
and [inaudible] Foundation also
expects that any research that comes
out of the research that they
fund will be publically accessible
immediately as it is, so that will
set new standards and I think more
and more foundations have
this request which means
that we are obliged to
coordinate our actions,
to make it interpretable
for other parties.
>> Jay?
>> One of the parts of IPERION is
looking [inaudible] how different
people photograph cross
sections and so a number
of people photograph the same
cross section and so a number
of institutions have changed
their photographic procedure
to [inaudible] everyone else did it
so when people can see a clear
benefit and improvement in process,
I think people are
willing to change.
It's only when perhaps there isn't a
clear indication for why [inaudible]
that you will get [inaudible].
>> Sure and I've been remind
for anyone speaking down here,
if you're going to say anything a
bit longer than a few words come
up here because we have
to have it on camera
but if I can paraphrase very, very
quickly, in the grounds project
that was presented very
quickly and will come up later,
no doubt about it, Joe Padfield
found that when there's a real need
for photographing in a different way
to compare grounds it actually
happened quite quickly.
You also have to adopt
one method don't you
so maybe this is a political
discussion, I'm not sure,
I'm just intrigued at how it
actually works in practice.
>> It depends on [inaudible].
>> Was there another hand up here?
>> I'm very curious too because the
SpinBook is something like Facebook-
[ Inaudible Comments ]
>> I'll repeat it,
SpinBook is like Facebook.
>> I'm very curious, I forgot to
ask this question, how do we control
that we don't have fake profiles
on SpinBook because I [inaudible]
for example and [inaudible]
for the rest of my life
and I will improve this
dream through a fake company
and put the company on SpinBook.
It is a nonsense question
I understand but I mean,
it has been filled with
something which is real,
which is connected to the reality.
How can we be sure that
what is inserted is real?
>> Let me just repeat the
question for the camera.
The very brief version
of the question was how do we
prevent fake identities appearing
on SpinBook whether it's a
company or another sort of profile?
>> In the entrance for there are
four people that will be a committee
in order to assess what is
getting into the system so up
to there, we cannot do any more.
We can [inaudible] I suppose
sometimes if something is,
now we have all the
capabilities, when we have an email
or a contact point inserted
by Googling it several
times you can have an idea
if something is fake
or something important.
There will be this committee in
order to make this check initially
and then we will decide if we
are going to leave the profile
or communicate with this guy.
>> Dou you want to come up Jay
if it's going to be a bit long
because this is a bit strange.
They're all going to
hear the question
and I'm going to have to repeat it.
I think we'll make
this the last question.
Come up, yeah.
>> Hello, I was just going to say
that people can apply for more
than one access at the
same time and sometimes
if people are putting together a
project which makes use of more
than one access that can be quite
beneficial and the other thing
to say is that members of IPERION
can't apply for these accesses
so it's all for people outside
of the project so it's not
like we can all apply for our own
access and it's all really great.
It's actually for other people
so the purpose of these sorts
of presentations are trying to get
other people to make applications
to IPERION because we can't
apply for our own accesses.
>> But all within Europe right Jay?
At the moment?
>> As far as I understand yes.
>> [Inaudible] you cannot
apply from the [inaudible]
which is in your country.
For instance, in Italy you cannot
apply for the Italian MOLAB
because they assess [inaudible].
>> Great well no more hands up.
We're going to take a quick
break, 15 minutes is good?
I want to say a few things but first
please thank our fantastic panel
for this.
>> My name is Barbara Berrie.
I'm head of the Scientific
Research Department
and I'm standing in for [inaudible].
Unfortunately, Emiliano [assumed
spelling] has a family health
emergency and our thoughts
are with him at this time.
I know he would have loved to have
been here with us and I also know
that I won't come even close
to being able to give you
as much information as
he has at his fingertips
but I have a great panel here, which
will help me work on all of this.
But before we get to the panel,
I just want to talk a little bit
about some of Emiliano's work.
He is one of those rare people who
works not only interdisciplinarily
but also truly multidisciplinary.
He's trained as a medievalist and
he has worked to build a platform
for the digital infrastructure
of research, digital research
in humanities and it's called
CENDARI and that stands for,
and I have it written down somewhere
pardon me, maybe somebody can find
which piece of paper
did I wrote this on,
it's the Collaborative European
Digital Archive Infrastructure
and in fact, there are some
pages in there that have
"technical documentation" and that
is really filled with information
and the kinds of words that I can't
get my head around like light F
and pineapple, RDF converters,
nerd (that one I do
know) and [inaudible].
All of these kinds of words that
describe what you need to know
in order to build this
kind of infrastructure
and I can't really get there
but I think that web page,
that documentation
shows it very well.
CENDARI is like DARIA, which
you've heard about and [inaudible],
and Parthenon and the new DIGILAB.
These are all pan European
initiatives that are being developed
as part of the infrastructure
to promote digital research
in humanities but today, I have a
great panel that's going to talk
about some of the nitty gritty
of doing that, really talking
about where the rubber meets the
road on this and about what kinds
of content we're trying to prepare
to be loaded into these kinds
of infrastructures and
some of the challenges
of not only the foundation for the
infrastructure but also the layers
on top that we will
be interfacing with.
Since everybody's bios are in the
program I'm not going to read those
and also because we're going
to change the format
up a little bit here.
I'm going to ask all the panelists
to speak for just five minutes
so we'll go through everybody's
project and perceptions
and then I'll come back with
specific questions that are tying
up some of the common
threads in the challenges
that each person is describing in
their effort and their endeavor,
and then I'll open
up the floor to you.
As you heard that there is no
microphone for you except these ones
so if you have a question or a
comment to make, there are plenty
of seats up in the front row so as
you're thinking of your questions
if you're going to want to ask some,
please come sit in the front row
and you can share the
microphones with us.
My panel starts, I'll introduce
everybody it's Merv Richard
who is Chief of Conservation
at the National Gallery
of Art, he's my boss [laughter].
Next to him is Joe Padfield
from National Galley of London,
Cecilia Frosinini who
is Vice Director
of the Opificio delle Pietre Dure in
Florence, Fenella France who is here
at the Library of Congress
and Michele Derrick,
who is at the Museum
of Fine Arts in Boston.
You'll notice that we're
mostly museum based people,
something that was noted to
and eluded to this morning,
that a lot of what goes on in
cultural heritage is happening
in museums in America but with that,
I think I'll start at the far end
and ask Merv to tell
us about his forays
into digital heritage research.
>> If you can't hear me then raise
your hand, I'll try to speak loudly.
Like most of you in this room,
I actually sit here
with multiple hats on.
The National Gallery actually
has a very long history
of doing collaborative projects,
both scientific research as well
as in conservation with
institutions around the world
and we have fostered that.
Now, there's a caveat here.
On the flip side, there's a long
tradition particularly in America
but maybe equally in Europe
of yes, you collaborate
with your collaborators
and you share information
but there's a long history
of conservators not wanting
to share information with
the much larger community
for a variety of reasons.
That's not why we're here today,
we're beyond that now thankfully
and for the purpose
of collaboration,
many of us have long felt the need
to share data much more extensively
than is possible through just
these mutual collaborations.
As a result, the National
Gallery, in partnership
with other museums including
some of you in this room,
has embarked with support
of the Mellon Foundation
and Alison is here today, I'm sure
you all know Alison or I hope so
but anyway, we have been
working for the last seven years
on something called
Conservation Space,
which some of you are familiar with
and Conservation Space is
directed towards the management
and preservation of the documents
that we generate in the course
of conservation as well as in
conservation science and the purpose
of it is to get away from filing
cabinets filled with pieces of paper
that typically require someone's
memory to remember oh yes,
we did such and such with such
and such 10 years ago and to get
into a situation where the
information is much more readily
accessible and by accessible
that can be
to your local conservation
community,
that can be to the entire
public if one wishes.
So with Conservation Space,
we looked for the development
of a digital took that would
number one, facilitate the day
to day working practices
of conservators
because if there's anything that
I've figured out over the years,
if you don't create something
that people actually want or need
to use then the likelihood
of them actually using
it is somewhat reduced
and with Conservation Space,
the objective was to find a way
of creating, storing, searching, as
well as sharing all of the records
that we are producing and when I
say records this is both in the form
of written documents
as well as images.
And so, I'm happy to say that
Conservation Space is live,
I mean it's real now,
it's not just a concept.
We've put it into production
at the National Gallery of Art
at the moment and we are sort
of doing a slow, rolled out use
of the software at the moment.
It is web based which means
that it lives in the cloud.
The information on a document
by document level can be made
accessible to user groups
that you define so in other
words, you can restrict it solely
to yourself, you can restrict it to
people collaborating on a project,
the people who collaborate can be
in the National Gallery or anywhere
in the world as long as they
have user access and if you want
to share it with the
whole world on a document
by document basis then you can
do that as well very easily.
The scientific department is
actually one of the most rapid,
I think, adopters of starting to
incorporate the scientific data
into the system and when
I say scientific data,
that means that it's in the form
of data tables and in the form
of things like images of graphs.
We are not trying to
address proprietary software
that instruments develop.
This is where we are and we feel
that this is a huge stride forward
in terms of collaboration, which
is what this meeting's all about
and look forward to sort of future
interactions with all of you.
>> Thanks Merv.
>> Good afternoon, I'm from the UK,
just one of the non-American
people [laughter],
there's two people from the EU.
I trained originally as a
chemist and then I trained
as a paintings conservator and then
I've spent the last 16 years working
with computers.
A lot of people working in cultural
heritage work with computers.
It's quite a normal thing where
that's just answering emails
or whether that's writing reports
or typing up questions or looking
at pictures and a lot of the
work that we're trying to do
at the moment is to
see how we can capture
that effort that's already
put in and make more of it.
So as Merv said, Conservation
Space is looking at trying
to simplify the administrative
structure that already exists
when you type in word documents but
instead of saving them in once place
on your computer, you save them in a
place that other people can see them
and managers can organize them.
It's a question of if we come up
with a beautiful computing system
that allows you to do all of the
things you'd like to do but all
of the work to do that is on top
of all of the work you already have
to do, it doesn't matter how good
the system is, no one is going
to use it they just don't have time.
So, in IPERION I'm responsible for
work package eight, which is looking
at developments in
digital documentation.
The budget is good.
It's not huge so we're not
looking to build systems
but what we're looking to do
is to test systems and as soon
as Merv releases Conservation Space
we're going to have a play with it
but it's looking to test ideas
of how people actually do things
so we're looking at small tools that
are being developed to help speed
up individual little jobs.
Now, as I said, people use
computers all the time anyway
but the thing is, there are large
numbers of IT professionals looking
for projects in universities
to do and then there's a lot
of cultural heritage scientists
struggling to answer questions
because of the limitations
of the software they have.
>> I'm not sure I understand.
[ Laughter ]
>> How appropriate, go Siri!
You need to speak more clearly Joe.
>> It's the accent.
>> Make the tool more simple.
>> I lost my train of thought
now so the question about is one
of the first tasks in work package
eight is making practical solutions
so actual things that people
can use, actual entities.
You mentioned a couple of those
terms that are on the CENDARI sort
of website you didn't like, like
RDF and the others and there's a lot
of informatics that can be hidden
underneath pieces of software
to allow people to do more
so there's an awful lot
of very clever technology sitting
underneath Conservation Space
that as a user you'd never
have to see it and care about,
but then a lot more is possible
with the information underneath.
What we're looking to do
is in the first task is
to provide tactical solutions
to actually show things working
and to show people how they
could do them themselves.
The second part of the work
package eight in IPERION is to look
at the descriptions, how do
we describe this information,
how do we be connected together so
most of you will be able to explain
to me what it is you do and
why you do it and what it is.
If you then had to explain
it to a computer in a way
that the computer could then
connect to other systems,
it becomes very difficult because
you have to be very, very specific
and consistent so that's what
the second task is looking at.
The third task is looking at
the notion of data formats,
it's that as we store more and
more of this information together,
how can we make sure that people
will be able to reuse it tomorrow
and in 10 years' time and in 20
years' time so as people have said,
we're not looking to replicate the
very quality pieces of software
that developed with instruments that
are purchased but to be able to look
at that data and to be able to
reuse the data later once these
instruments no longer work and once
the software is no longer available
is becoming important as we're
generating huge amounts of data
in some of these new techniques
that are becoming available
so that's the third task.
And then the final task within
work package eight is actually
to produce resources of
information that people could use
and move forward so it's
been discussed already one
of the first ones you're looking at
a grounds database so we're going
to try and look at building
a database of ground samples
and explain how they all
connect together, how they relate
to the different artists
and different institutions
where the information is stored but
we're also going to try and build
that on a fairly generic
model so that
that same database
structure can be used
for other resources of information.
So, how it can be used
for quantitative analysis
of [inaudible] is going to
be another one that's going
to be looked at but we are
looking at practical solutions
to doing these things so
Conservation Space, and I won't go
into actual numbers, had a
much bigger budget than we have
within the particular work
package we're dealing with.
There was another very interesting
project which is hopefully just
about to be released called Research
Space, which is going to be allowed
to do different jobs, to do
with complex cultural
heritage information and again,
we're looking to make use of
these and use them and test them
within IPERION rather than try
and write them again because a lot
of people are working on
similar projects and ideally
through communication it
would be great to make sure
that we can each use each other's
work to move forward rather
than continuing replicating
the stuff that goes forward
so there are lots of resources out
there, people are working on them,
there's lots of really good
work being done and we're trying
to improve the communications
and provide real worked examples
so that Siri can understand what it
is [laughter] we're actually doing
and it's often a lot of these
complex projects are done,
the project comes to an end, there's
a very shiny product at the end
of it, everyone really likes it
and then a new project stars up
and they go well, we're
not going to use
that because we don't know
how it works and well,
we're not sure we can do it so they
start again and build it again.
If we can make sure that these tools
are being developed are building
blocks, we can move forward
and the golden rule is make
sure you can get your data out,
actually it doesn't really matter
what the software is as long
as you can get your data in
and you can get your data out,
you can move on to
whatever's going to happen next
so these are the things
we're looking
at within work package eight
for the IPERION project.
>> Thanks Joe, Cecilia maybe you'll
talk about some of these issues
from a slightly different
perspective.
>> Yes, always a different
perspective because I feel
at a certain point
always out of context
because I [inaudible] mainly working
with the scientist or a conservator
and so sometimes I feel
like a child of a lesser God
because it's very difficult
that people trust me,
people from the scientific
point of view.
It's very difficult to make me
reliable from their point of view
and also when I come back
to my original field,
to my original background
and discuss
with traditional academic art
historians, I am always the child
of a lesser God because of course,
I mix my origin and great tradition,
God given experience and scholarship
for very trivial kind of studies
so this is very interesting
from some point of view.
It's a continuous challenge
but this is also the challenge
of the great change that Italy
experienced especially in the field
of conservation because for many,
many decades in the
last century especially,
the art historians were not really
involved in conservation but some
of them, very few of them
and generally speaking
they were all involved
in the research regarding
the museum,
and the exhibition, and so on.
And also, there was a very
low level consideration
for the conservation field.
Conservators were considered more
like the craftsmanship of art.
They were not considered a high
level position and it lasted
for a long time so I
think that in some ways,
this idea of art separated from
science affected the development
of also the material art history
which is very, very behind in Italy.
In our experience at the
Opificio delle Pietro Dure,
we have this pioneeristic position
because we have always thought
to be a sort of Italian branch of
the [inaudible] and also because one
of our founding fathers [inaudible]
was very close to all the people
of the [inaudible] who founded the
school of the [inaudible] tradition
but we were very distant
from the rest of the world.
I think that in time and of
course these last decades,
these gaps have been filled
and are already filled
and now we share our
expertise and we participate
to all the major projects.
For example, in the case of IPERION,
I think it is very important choice
that Opificio made to appoint three
different people as representatives
in the frame of the different
task leaders of IPERION
so we have a scientist, a
conservator and an art historian,
which is a sort of coronation of all
the story that I have tried to send
up during this short work.
I think that I have benefitted
a lot as an art historian
from this continuous experience
and this continuous
sharing with the scientists.
Most of the modern accomplishments
of art history cannot be
so grounded, so based on the truth
in my opinion and especially what I
like very much is the fact
that now it can deny many
of the urban legends that were at
the basis of many constructions
of the academic art
historians so I think
that this has been my personal
experience but also a general change
in Italy for the professional
of art history.
>> Fenella, tell us about
your initiatives here.
>> So I wanted to, can you
hear me okay at the back?
So, I wanted to start
by sort of going back
to Professor [inaudible] talking
about stem to steam this morning
because we're hearing
this theme come through
and I really adhere very
strongly to the fact that we need
to integrate the humanities and
the scientific data together
because they're not separate,
they actually rely on each other
and then also in terms of GLAM,
everyone keeps talking about museums
and I kind of want to put my
finger up and say no, I'm a library
but we do science here too so we
have galleries, libraries, archives
and museums, historic houses, all of
these institutions I think we need
to think a little bit more
broadly in terms of our concept
because the academic institutions,
many of them also have museums
and libraries and I
very much want to pick
up on Luca's [phonetic] point
this morning where he talked
about data not just being
the captured document
but the physical collection and
I'll come back to that at the end,
but we have many libraries
and museums
who have physical collections,
reference collections
that are being shared.
And so, I think that comes back
to what is data, both physical
and digital components of the
same and as part of that too,
what are archives and repositories
because the repositories
are reference collections
that when people retire are getting
thrown out and we all just cringe
in horror when that happens,
really are critical parts
of our institutions that
we need to be preserving.
There's many institutions with
lots of different initiatives
and I very much like what
Joe was saying that we want
to be interoperable
and we really want
to build upon each other's
initiatives so if I do a small piece
that actually is useful for
something else, I'd really rather
like my system to be agnostic
and actually interact
with everyone else's.
And so we've talked, we've
heard about Conservation Space,
Research Space, these [inaudible]
which I'll talk about in a moment
but also a little bit broader so
I don't know how many of you know
about [inaudible], which is a
partnership between the Association
of Research Libraries and
the Institute for Museum
of Library Studies and the
Sloane Foundation for the Center
for Open Science so I think these
are initiatives we also need
to be engaging with
and not reinventing
when they're already looking
at ways of sharing that data
and trying to make that open.
Delighted to have Cliff
Lynch[assumed spelling] here
from the Coalition for
Networked Information
and that's something also
we need to really look
at what other institutions we
should be engaging with as well
because that allows us to use and
reuse our data more effectively,
because if we all have data sets and
as we've heard, they've been used
for one purpose, we often don't know
what a different audience might want
to use them for and I think that's
something we really need to push
on a lot more, to look
at the other audiences
that might be interested
in what we're doing.
In terms of the collaboration
for sharing data and Joe
and I will talk more about
this tomorrow but you know part
of it really comes down to
the institutional policy
and at what level management
supports that sharing
and what level of sharing that is.
There may be different models for
really looking at what type of data
and how you can share
that level of data.
I just wanted to finish up
with talking about CLASSD,
another acronym, the Center
for Library Analytical
Scientific Samples.
Here at the library we both have
physical reference materials of all
of the types of materials that
we have in our collections
and have been linking that to a
web accessible database of all
of the data that links back to
that original object or sample.
Part of that has been trying
to drive ourselves crazy
by extracting metadata from
proprietary instruments
and encouraging the manufacturer's
that we really don't want
to steal the software, we
just want to extract the data
so really looking at what
are those open, sustainable,
file formats that we can do
that we can extract that from,
what other high level metadata we
need for people to be able to share
and actually engage with that
database more effectively
and then pulling that out of
that nonproprietary format.
It came up this afternoon about
the verification and validation
of the accuracy of the data so
part of this is actually insuring
that there are experts who
are expert in a certain type
of data analysis, I told Michele
that she is going to be put on here,
that would actually be verifying
the accuracy of that data
to make sure before it's put out
there, that that has been validated
and then in terms of assuring
that we don't have fake
institutions created
that there would be member partners
who would engage and have to be part
of their [inaudible] agreement
and then any other researchers
from that institution would
have the expirable account
that would go through
the institution.
One thing I will talk about a
lot more tomorrow is this sharing
of reference collections and
I know a lot of us have talked
about the fact that we can't
all have all of the same types
of materials but it's been
wonderful working with Michele
because we've actually
been capturing data on some
of our [inaudible] and pushing
that into the CAMEO collection
so I think really a more coherent
approach which we're all advocating
for and seeing how much we can
use of each other's initiatives
to really get that global
perspective as Luca's been pushing
and to move us all
forward to next steps.
>> Michele, maybe you just had
the introduction on CAMEO there.
Maybe you can talk about
that and your development
of an online digital resource.
>> Okay thank you.
I'm going to talk about
something a little different
because this is CAMEO,
the Conservation
and Art Materials Encyclopedia
Online, that has been online
for over 16 years so, and
because I've worked on it
for about 20 years,
I've got to brag.
We actually made the cover page
for Chemistry International,
September 2016.
[ Applause ]
>> We have, in the month of
November we had 11,200 users,
that's independent IP addresses.
We have about 60 editors,
23 of which are in Europe
and CAMEO now resides
on media wiki software
so I think what I'm supposed to talk
about though is how did
we get to this point?
How did it actually develop?
The main thing, I thought
I was talking loud okay,
the main thing I think is that
we were a single institution
that was focused on
a single subject.
Now, our subject is fairly broad,
materials used in art or used
in conservation or
materials that can affect art
so that can be pigments, coatings,
adhesives, formaldehyde, insects,
but we had a topic and
we had an institution.
We had several people that
were allowed to work on it
and we received generous grants
so we received an initial grant
from the National Center
for Preservation Technology
and Training, we received one
from the Institute of Museum
and Library Surfaces,
IMLS, we received one
from the Mellon Foundation and
one from the Crest Foundation.
Each of these grants in general
helped us migrate the data
from an older platform onto a new
platform but it also allowed us
to do some data addition
and alteration and changes.
We went from File Maker,
to Microsoft Access to SQL,
to a proprietary software that we
were stuck in for about 10 years
and had trouble getting our data
out of and now we're on media wiki
and let's see, one of the most
important things that happened
to CAMEO was our collaboration
with Europe and this was started
by the dedication of Jean-Louis
Boutain [assumed spelling],
who contacted me in 2005, and set
up a working group with [inaudible]
and Jean-Louis Boutain
pushed people.
Because of the goal of
transnational access, we thought one
of the most important things was
to add foreign language synonyms
to the English language records so
that those could be searched on so
that anyone could get access to the
records and after [inaudible] ended,
then we became a working
group in CHARISMA
and that gets us to
where we are now.
I did some statistics at
the beginning of CHARISMA.
We had 48 percent of the users
were outside the US and now
as of November 2016, 63 percent
of the users are outside of the US
and in November of 2016, we
were used in 139 countries
so I very much have
enjoyed working on this.
>> Well Michele, that's
great so this is an example
of if you build it, they will
come but that has been one
of the questions that's been raised
by people funding and people working
on developing infrastructures
for digital research
and so your 11,000
users are from all over.
Do you know if they're using
it for high school papers,
for technical art history,
for painting?
>> I have no idea.
One of the things about CAMEO
is that when it started,
there wasn't much competition out
there however, now there are lots
of data bases that are very
specific for painting materials,
for adhesives, for stones,
etc so one of the things
we're doing is linking
to those different databases and I
check the people that are linking
to CAMEO and one of the museums
is the Metropolitan Museum.
They have their wonderful art
historical database that's
phenomenal and they actually link
to CAMEO for specific informations
on the materials that are
used in the works of art.
>> Maybe Joe, I can
just ask you a question
about the IPERION initiatives.
Have you in your work package
said who your audience should be?
>> Yes and no.
Because that particular work
package one of the tasks is looking
at building resources, most of the
work is actually building process,
how do you actually do jobs?
The audience of the actual resources
at the end are primarily aiming
towards cultural heritage scientists
so people that actually
wanted to research rather
than people just having
to explore it for fun.
The intention is that the resources
will be open to the wider public
but they're not being written
in such a way to engage with,
it's simply a different level of
resource that would be required
to actually produce that.
>> Merv, Conservation Space
on the other hand is written
for a specific audience
in its concept.
>> Right in terms of concept I mean,
Conservation Space is being
developed to solve a problem
in institutions which is to
facilitate the actual work processes
or workflow of practicing
conservators
and conservation scientists.
Now, when I say that, in essence
though what we're developing is a
document management system that is
intended for museums and libraries
and in fact, some of the
biggest users may end
up being conservators in libraries.
From that standpoint it is solving a
specific problem but then when I say
that we already have curators at the
National Gallery who are interested,
oh can I use that as a research
tool and the answer is yes.
So, it actually has expandability
and one thing to emphasize here
for those of you who are
familiar with semantic approaches
to database development, I mean,
Conservation Space is built on top
of a significant Open Source
platform at the bottom-most layers,
something called Alfresco
[assumed spelling], for the techies
in the room and then there's
a platform on top of that,
that the company we're working
with [inaudible] developed
and it's a semantic
database and the advantage
of the semantic approach is that the
ability to now map to and interact
with other databases
is expanded in our view
and so you can link to
many other databases.
>> You know, thinking of linking
makes me think about librarians
and archivists and finding
resources so I'm really glad
that we have Fenella here but I
think one thing that these objects
that are tools proliferate
our ability
to discover them is
going to be challenged.
But one of the ways that this
can be helped is by the linking
and I'm interested in hearing
how much linking is going on
but Fenella, perhaps I could ask
you do we need to have standards
if we're going to be
linking among databases?
Or are there ways to get around that
or should we think about that now?
>> So it's come up a few
times today that, you know,
will people do what you want them
to do and I think the challenge is
that whenever I, I started this
initiative about nine years ago
and I asked all my colleagues
at the time what do you want
to see in this database?
And basically they said,
put something up there
because we don't really
know until we see something
so that wasn't really particularly
helpful but I think you really need
to start from a standard and
then what we have done is try
to standardize the
approach of the open access,
the standardized file formats,
extracted metadata, engaging people
who are expert in different
instrument, but also then trying
to make sure that the structure
is robust enough to add
in addition fields when people
suddenly say wait a minute,
there's another way of
describing this that we can now do,
we have a new instrument,
can we add that in?
So part of it is I really do
think we really do need to try
to standardize because otherwise
one of the challenges we all have is
that being such a multidisciplinary
field
when one person says data someone
else hears something different
and I think we've all
had that discussion
where we're using exactly
the same words and at the end
of the discussion, five people have
gone in 12 different directions
so one of the challenges is
how much we can have some sort
of shared terminology
while still recognizing
that there are nuances in there.
But yes, in order to share we do
need to do that, but the data needs
to be in a format that
is usable to that user.
So for example, I may
be using something
in a completely different
way to Joe or Michele,
but as long as that data is in a
structure that they can extract
and reuse then I think that's
the critical component.
>> So along those lines
Cecilia, the kind of information
that you would want to pull from
a digital repository or asset?
X-radiographs, cross-sections?
>> Yes, everything [laughter].
>> She doesn't want too much,
but some of these files
are going to be huge right?
>> Yeah.
>> And how do you guide an
art historian to looking
at them on a digital database?
>> Here comes the problem
of the location especially
in the university I think.
We are struggling but I think
that probably [inaudible]
the key person tomorrow
to explain better this problem
in the modern university regarding
the conservation scientist,
their key role as a sort of bridge
between the traditional
art historian,
the traditional scientist.
From my point of view, I think that
we need to have a very important,
at this point, it is very important
to have a generation of teachers
that try to train these new kind of
figures and this is very important.
For example, in Florence, the
University of Florence has a school
of specialization for art historians
which is really a very formal,
very academic but they have
selected some specific courses,
one is called scientific diagnostic
for art historians,
which is very nice.
It's a sort of [inaudible]
you could say
so you know what [inaudible] was,
it was trying to teach to the son
of the King of France whose formal
title was the [inaudible] of course
and try to explain that in an
easier way and the very basic
of all the subjects for the cultures
so I think this idea that comes
in our university to have
for example diagnostics
for art historian is
something interesting
because you are not aimed to
explain them all the principles
of chemistry, or physics or
whatever but to try to teach them
which are the questions and which
are the more probable investigations
that can give some
answers to these questions.
So I think that this is a good idea
and this is also probably the idea
that we could keep in mind when
trying to build this linking
between all the different databases
so you need different users.
>> I think we might
need new librarians too,
to help the art historian
going to the library
to discover these tremendous assets
because so far as I can tell,
some of these are available already,
you just have to know where to look.
But in terms of training,
I wasn't actually thinking
of getting the conversation
on to training quite yet
but if we can just stay
on that for a moment,
Merv and Joe you both trained
as conservators so you had
to have some science and I
think both of you actually came
with science undergraduates rather
than art history as undergraduates
and then picking up
science as a conservator,
but if you can cast your minds
back, how difficult was it
to have one class with some
people with a science background
and some people with none
to have the same class?
How do we need to solve
this problem?
Who can be the trainers
for the art historians?
>> I remember people
breaking out into tears trying
to explain certain
aspects of science.
I think the difficulty with
this type of training is
that you don't necessarily
want to turn an art historian
into a chemist or an
IT professional.
You want to give the art
historian enough understanding
to know the questions they
should be asking or to know
who they should be
asking the questions of.
I think for university students,
we need to tell them you're an
art historian, you need to go
to a chemistry class, insuring
that they understand the purpose
of the chemistry class is to
allow them to ask questions rather
than for them to become a
chemist is quite important.
Having a clear understanding of
what people are trying to learn,
so I would have thought for
an art historian the best way
to get information together on
a particular artist would be
to get every single object ever
created by that artist into one room
to gather together all of
the historical examinations
that have been done of all of
those objects into the one room,
and then all of the specialists
who did all of that work
into the one room, all at your
beck and call and with a few people
to interpret the different
languages that were done.
Now theoretically, you could come
up with a computer model to do that
but that's kind of where we're
aiming towards and I would say
that a big issue here is
trust because if we're looking
at pulling information from lots of
different places, you need to know
where it's coming from
and that you can trust it.
We've got a lot of stuff in the main
press at the moment about fake news,
which is slightly more severe
but people need to know
if an examination has been
done, where was it done,
do you feel that's an
okay interpretation
because people aren't generally
going to be able to understand all
of the raw data underneath
even if it's available.
>> That was the case before it was
digital too wouldn't you agree?
>> Yes.
>> It's just that now with
the proliferation of access,
we have to be more careful.
>> You just have more
questions, that's the difficulty.
I mean, instead of sort of spending
20 years exploring an archive,
you may spend a week exploring
four so you're going to be hit
by so much more information.
Understanding that you
can make quick decisions
about what you found
could be quite important.
>> Thanks.
Michele, you have CAMEO
which started off you said
with a rather broad remit
but can you talk a little bit
about the data landscape
and how starting
from there might have changed how
you decide what you're curating
in your archive, your
digital archive?
>> Sure so, at the point we started
CAMEO, we were taking information
from the books on our
library shelves
and putting it into
a digital format.
Because the books were being
submitted to me and I was putting it
into the format, I had
a standardized structure
that I used for every single record.
>> So wait, can I just say that
goes back to your fidelity issue?
These were books Michele
that you trusted.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Yes and it's documented still
in the CAMEO records what
data sources were used
to generate information in that
record and when I found data sources
that had discrepant information,
it's actually recorded there
because I found them and I'm
sorry, I lost my train of thought.
>> How did it grow?
It grew from just taking the
traditional kinds of material
from books and spread out?
>> Right, exactly so the first
database for CAMEO was textual only.
When we got it into the SQL format
then we were allowed to add images
so we actually had an image
collection specialist that was able
to take a lot of micrographs
himself,
he pulled all the [inaudible]
pictures off he could off
and added them there, he searched
the web for other pictures
and put them in with credits
and we expanded to that,
and then we started putting
data in so we have IR data,
[inaudible] data, x-ray
defraction, x-ray fluorescence,
polarized light images, anything
we could get for the materials.
Some of that came from
our conservation records,
some from our scientific records,
others from other people
submitting them.
>> And Fenella, along those
lines with CLASSD, is that to try
and help fidelity of the
digital part of the content?
How do we also make sure that
we're not getting fuzzy spots
on the x-radiographs
that Cecilia's cohort-
>> So it's a combination you know
I think of what we've always done
with the analog and then the expert
and Michele is intimately involved
with [inaudible] as well but
going from that sort of model
where you have an expert
who will be responsible
for a specific instrumental
technique
so you know this does not look
right and it gets sent back,
so the combination of both
but also just allowing
for more discoverability.
I think that everyone's doing so
much work and even when I hear
about a different initiative, I had
three weeks to just even shut myself
in a room and look at some of these
initiatives but there's so much data
out there that we just don't
know and we're not linking to
and I think that's a
critical point that's coming
through that there's a lot of data
there that's not being shared,
it's not being saved, funding
stops and it disappears somewhere
and that's where I
think we need to capture
that before we lose all
of that historic data.
>> Now on that note, I'd like to
open up the conversation to all
of you and as I said there's a
microphone right here, you can come
and sit in seats as you're thinking
of the questions, or you can shout
out and I'll transmit the
information into the microphone.
>> I can shout, I think
I'm loud enough.
>> You can stand near
the microphone.
>> I'm near it.
Hi, my question is I guess for the
group but particularly for Fenella
and Michele, I'm interested
in the accessibility of data.
We have some systems like
the [inaudible] database,
which holds infrared
and [inaudible] data
that is only available
by membership.
You contribute and then you're
able to use and you have
to be an institution to use these.
I used to work as a
private conservator
and I did not have access to
these databases and I make a point
that I try to get my students
membership so that they,
as they go through their
career and they move from place
to place will always have access
to these kinds of systems.
I personally believe that we
might curate the data we put up
but that we should let people use
it freely however they want just
as they would use a book.
I'm wondering what your thoughts
are on that and your experiences.
>> Well I can simply say that
CAMEO is open to the public.
Anyone can access it,
it's free of charge,
and there never will be a charge.
The MFA is committed to
keeping it accessible.
>> And with CLASSD, that's the same.
I talked about the fact that
we would start with sort
of member partners because we want
to engage and encourage other people
to put their data in so that was
the place to start with that,
but it will be a registered user
and so there's no cost for that.
People are not required but we
really wanted to start with partners
so that we would get more than
add data because there's a lot
of much more interesting data out
there so to answer your question,
the data set of whatever
there is will be available
and can be combined so for one
sample we'll have the [inaudible],
all of that linked to
the one object or sample.
>> Joe?
>> I was just going to say that
there are lots of sort of databases
that are created that for various
reasons do need to be protected
or closed to a certain extent.
I think one of the very important
things to do about that is
to record why they're closed and if
there's a time limit on the closing.
I think some of the
projects like [inaudible],
they were essentially
closed to begin
with to insure people contributed.
I think at a certain point perhaps
they could be then made open again
because it's reached
that critical mass.
That's where you put that type of
data, that's where you would go
for that type of data so
if people could access
that information then that's
great but I think to allow people
to start off with a plan
and a slightly more closed
environment helps people
with the engaging with
that to being with,
but there should be
a time limit on it.
I mean, once after so
many years have gone
by why can't other people use it?
I think if that type of
thing can be captured,
that can be really important and
often, people end up doing stuff
because that's the way we do it so
yes, it's closed because it's closed
and it's sort of a
circular argument.
If it's closed because it's
closed then why can't we open it?
I would agree with you the notion
that if information isn't actually
of a secret or personal nature
then if it can be used then great.
>> Maybe you can, and
I'll come back to Cecilia,
just discuss the structure
of Conservation Space allows
different levels of permissions.
>> Yeah I mean with Conservation
Space there are two aspects
to this question.
I mean, one is from the
standpoint of sustainability
and since Conservation Space
is intended to actually help
with work processes then while the
software is made available freely,
in order to maintain the software
into the future there will have
to be some kind of membership
fee which is associated
with just sustaining the software
and continuing to develop it.
But in terms of them who is made
accessible since on a document
by document level and with
the assignment of user roles,
it means that you have
the capability of opening
up those documents to
however broad a group you want
so that you're not making a decision
from the onset about
who can see what.
You're deciding that this class of
documents the whole world can see it
if they wish and so that's
where the flexibility
in how you approach it
can make a difference.
>> Part of the structure
of the system allows
that and Cecilia you want to-
>> Yes, I just wanted to point
to the fact that in Italy,
we have a specific legislation about
how this data can be accessible
or not because most of the works
of art are property of the state,
so we are compelled
to follow these rules.
These rules are very old
because usually they were set
only considering the photographs,
the traditional kind of
photographs but they assume
that there should be an
authorization all the time
that you ask for data coming
from different archives
so now all the database
that pertains to research,
to scientific investigation and
so on are put in the same box
like they were photographs because
there is no specific legislation
about all this kind of analysis.
And according to these laws, we
need to ask for the authorization
of the museum, of the church
or whatever, who is the owner
of the paintings despite the fact
that the investigations are carried
out by sometimes other
institutions, or universities,
or so on so you need
a great collection
of authorizations sometimes.
That makes things really, really
difficult so that's the reason most
of these database are just for being
consulted, being read, being used
but you cannot really retrieve
your original document.
You cannot print an x-ray
or whatever without asking
for a formal authorization.
>> It shows that we still are
treating digital information
sometimes the way we
treated analog information.
We haven't actually
adjusted our thoughts.
I think the permission level
that Merv talked about is a way
to maybe help institutions
deal with that.
Fenella, you have some thoughts too?
>> Yes, I just wanted to follow
on from both the user role
and the access because one thing
we put into place was the fact
that while we have
public domain so we have
to make everything accessible but
partners may not want to put all
of their collections out there and
so each partner would have control
of their collection to say okay,
this came from a specific donor,
we want to just keep this
for our in house location
but this we will share, so there
would be those sorts of levels
that would allow people to
decide at what point they make
that accessible and
how they do that.
>> One thing is clear is if I
have to say which is the priority
in the data, it is
clear to me that a lot
of information are already
available [inaudible] by all
of us [inaudible] [laughter].
There are many different
types of databases.
Now, [inaudible] how to
make them work together,
how you can bring together
whether this can be done
through the invention
of another database.
I mean, this is something
that does not make me happy.
What makes me happy is what
Barbara was saying perhaps we need
to train people on how to
look for the information.
I mean, I have many courses
at the University of Bologna.
One of the key courses [inaudible]
32 hours of frontal lesson
and 18 lessons of laboratory.
The first six hours of the 32
are just related with how to look
through the website
on the information
that is already available on
a given particular [inaudible]
such as malachite.
We want to know everything
about malachite,
where can we find this information
and then you train them regardless
whether they are librarians
or in this case they will be
conservation scientists first of all
where to look, where to
find this information
because they are already available.
If you move a painting, I mean it
is very difficult to find the x-ray
that [inaudible] because
as you say most
of this information
has property rights
and so they are not public not
because they cannot be made public
but because there are rules
that do not allow you to make it
so this information is frozen
there within the institution.
This is why the [inaudible]
is becoming so important
because what they are looking
for is all of the information
which is not available and
probably will not be available
because they are forced
to stay where they are
because of many reasons,
the last one is
that perhaps there are
institutions that don't want
to make their house
section available
to the others just because they are-
>> Theirs.
>> Just because they are theirs and
this is my job, I took a lot of time
to do this job and I don't want the
others to be part of this so we have
to consider all of these
cultural diversity if you want
because it relates also
with different types
of cultural diversity so the key
point is the accessibility of data,
not how to structure the already
available data in something else,
how to make the accessibility
even more easy, in my opinion.
>> Well, time will
take care of that one.
>> What?
>> Time will take care of that.
People will die off, you know?
[ Laughter ]
>> Not us but you know-
>> And actually, if I could just
talk to that, this is something
that came up very strongly when
we had the meeting in 2014,
that we need a better communication
platform and ways to actually link
to all of these different
initiatives because you know,
I think there's so much going
on that all these meetings
that were being mentioned and I
think Luca was saying he got invited
to a meeting two days
away, how do we make,
this is a little bit past
the data but if we don't know
that a meeting is on we
don't know where that is,
so I think that's another
part that we need to think
about is how we communicate
and link more effectively
between all our institutions.
>> Another aspect of this is,
I mean a while ago you were
asking the question about the fact
that conservators come
from different disciplines
so many have a background
in art history or studio art
with limited chemistry
or vice versa.
And so, there's a learning that
takes place during the course
of conservation training where
everybody has their strengths
and weaknesses and everybody
helps each other out.
Now, one thing that is a bit of
a problem when you look at people
who are strictly studying
art history
for example is relatively
few academic programs
at the university level are
emphasizing the technical aspects
of art history that I'm aware of.
It's gradually changing I
think but this is an area
where I think many art historians
either enter the academic world
or the curatorial world
without having an introduction
to the technical aspects of
it in a very solid way anyway
and so they happen upon it because
of personal interest or because
of their experience
wherever they are.
So, I think influencing
the academic training
of art historians is one what that
we could influence the future.
I think one thing that's
very good is
because we have become
much more effective
at presenting our information
visually,
that has really increased
dramatically an interest
in what many people are
calling technical art history
because obviously reading tables
of numbers does not go over well
with many art historians but if
you can look at pictures or images
that have been mapped to
show you specific information
about where's malachite in
this particular painting mapped
on an image or the dramatic
increase in what we can do
with hyperspectral and other-
>> Yeah, I think simple
imaging tools
like Photoshop have helped
take us to that first step
and the more advanced digital tools
that are being developed
specifically for our use
in layering multiple different kinds
of technical information in a way
that gives an image
that an art historian
like Cecilia can actually
work through
and decode has moved us
significantly together
over the past few years,
which is a wonderful thing.
People do say that vocabulary has
been a great divide between the arts
and the sciences but I think it's
not just vocabulary, it's also ways
of thinking and I think
we should get into that.
Before we go on with vocabulary,
someone has a question here.
>> It's more a remark as a question.
I think for [inaudible] where
malachite is in a picture
for instance, might
also be very interested
to know [inaudible] educated
laypeople say oh that's what I'm
looking at so Photoshop
is one way of looking
at it so that's my remark.
>> Oh Joe, while Jorgen's coming
up do you want to, are you,
okay all right, now we're getting-
[ Laughter ]
>> All right Joe you get to go
first because you're on the panel
and then Luca, then Jorgen
and anybody else wants to come
and ask a question,
you've got to get in line.
>> Take a number.
>> I was just going to
say we need to remember
that this has the potential
for multiple different types
of research happening at the same
time so if you have an art historian
who is researching the use
of a particular pigment
that's a particular job,
there's a particular skill
set involved in that.
If you then have a scientist
researching the analysis
of a particular pigment, that's an
entirely different form of research.
You can then have a digital,
I don't remember the term,
someone doing digital humanities
who's exploring how you present
information on that
particular thing.
There are a number of different
things to do and to sort
of address Rocco's point
beforehand, you spend sort
of six hours training them
how to find these pigments-
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Yeah but it's a question
about how many times do you do
that before you work out,
just put it all in one place
and then they can all find it?
If you looked back 20 years ago,
how long would it have taken them
to find the same information?
Now, it's not their research
to make it more accessible,
that's the thing.
It's someone else's research
to make it accessible
but if you've got a lot of
informatics people doing research,
if you effectively can
say it takes us six hours
to do this can you do it faster, can
we direct the research that's done
by other people to make
our research easier?
I think that's a tricky one because
often conservation science borrows
from so many different fields we
can end up feeling it's our job
to do everything whereas
that's not actually possible.
Because we work
in an interdisciplinary field
it's very good to be able
to say this is my area,
it's not my job to do that
but it would be really handy
if someone else can do it
and then more we can
gather these questions,
these issues that are
actually stopping people
or slowing people down, we can
help each other move forward.
>> It's true.
>> Luca? You want to weigh
in and ask a question?
>> Yes, more than a question I
need kind of advice for the panel
and not only from the panel but you
may remember that we [inaudible].
I remember having several
conversations with [inaudible]
about where we are aiming to.
By the way [inaudible]
so we will continue this
cooperation [inaudible].
Coming back to the point, maybe
we are too crazy visionaries,
too [inaudible] but I
need to know we are aiming
to because we are actually
aiming somewhere
and we had this nice
[inaudible] too.
My personal feeling and I've
been involved in [inaudible],
my feeling is that we need to speak
about [inaudible] stone
age problems.
We are speaking about
[inaudible] useless without tools.
Maybe it could be useful to
teach how to extract information
on malachite but that's
very [inaudible].
You have the digital system there,
maybe [inaudible]but I expect
that I will be able to ask my
digital research assistant very
complex questions in the near
future and in our field I'd say one
of these questions could be
look, I found this manuscript.
There's a very nice section
of drawing [inaudible] similar
or related to [inaudible]
maybe before the age
of that document and after it.
Are you able to do that?
Of course we need the
software [inaudible]
but if you don't have the database
accessible you will not have the
software because nobody's
going to develop the software
for a non-accessible database
or a nonexistent database
and if you get only the
database but not the tools,
you will not [inaudible].
I think the most important knowledge
infrastructure around is Google
because [inaudible] of the knowledge
that is freely available [inaudible]
so we need to aim to this
[inaudible] situation
where we can have research
in a [inaudible] heritage
and humanities and in [inaudible].
When I'm studying an
object I put [inaudible]
so if I'm studying a stone
I can access the inscription
and everything that has been studied
and when I'm studying inscription
[inaudible] I can access the stone
[inaudible] historical
context because the way
of doing research is
doing correlation
and correlation can be only for the
moment done by humans but you need
to provide the information
to the humans [inaudible].
That information must be there
and in this very moment we are
discussing possible potential
information there with the
exception of the [inaudible]
but we cannot survive
without [inaudible] tools
because this infrastructure
is databases plus tools,
that will provide infrastructure
services.
>> I think Luca has put his
finger on one of the challenges
for doing the research, the
discoverability of information
but then the intellectual part of
doing research requires our ability
to synthesize and I think we do rely
on Google and we are going to have
to get over that in a little while.
Jorgen, you had a comment
or a question.
>> Yeah well it is both,
you mentioned that technical
art history isn't being taught
in very many places.
It is coming up more and more and
we are now a two year master course
in English at the University of
Amsterdam in technical art history
where anybody here
[inaudible] and University
of Stockholm they're
starting up in September '17,
also a two year master for
technical art history combining the
traditional art history and I
see from the colleagues I meet
with in [inaudible] that there is
more and more questions being aired
about technical aspects of the
objects that they are curating
in the galleries but also
having more and more questions
to the validity of the
science that they are provide
so they will ask these groups
more and more questions related
to getting access to
the data we have
and their questions will
be more and more complex,
and they will question whether
the data is trustworthy.
I mentioned in my presentation
[inaudible] dates
that are being provided actually
are validated because there are
so many aspects of [inaudible]
dating that are in the open
so what is the date in
reality and the more that kind
of a question comes, the more it
comes to us as [inaudible] group
to provide sufficient amount
of valid and validated data
and I think the market will be
increasing particularly also thanks
to the database that [inaudible]
the questions will be more complex
and they will be [inaudible].
>> May I ask the audience if
anyone has an idea of a tool
that they wish was already existing
to help them do their research
in digital humanities
or digital art history?
So, we're not quite getting the
message out of what's available
to be used so Cecilia, your group,
we need to maybe help them think
about what tools they would
need to crack open some
of the digital data we have
and that's where Jorgen,
your work with training will
help people devise the questions
that then we build the tools to
answer, to crack open because some
of these things are
hard like walnuts.
Well, if there are no more questions
and since Fenella has offered to,
but before actually, before
we do that I'm just going
to give everybody on the panel
another one minute if they want
to summarize their
thoughts about where we are
and where they think we should be
going next especially maybe in terms
of reacting to some of the
questions that have come up.
Michele, shall we start with
you at this end this time?
You're feeling good about CAMEO.
>> Yeah, I'm feeling good except
Joe has introduced me to a lot
of possibilities of things that
can be done now that CAMEO is
on the media wiki platform as far
as because now it's multiple pages
that you can search for but
apparently there's applications
out there that you can ask
questions and it can pull a set
of pages together in a group
and create answers to more
than just the straight
single material questions.
>> That actually would
be really interesting.
I was just thinking about some of
these things which are like books
that have the first page for
the introductory learner,
the middle pages for
the student learner
and the whole chapter
is for the researcher.
And the truth is that
the digital assets
that we are building have
information at all of those levels.
The challenge is to use them
at our appropriate level
so if you're going to
start that's great.
>> Well hopefully it gives me
something new to think about.
>> That's great.
Fenella, concluding thoughts?
>> So I think that very much making
the data accessible is critical
but coming back to the datamining
and the tools, it certainly has
to be there and I was on a working
group at the library a number
of years ago and the whole
point they were saying was well,
we've got this data,
it's freely accessible
but the point was there's no way
for people to actually get to it
and mine it and so I think those
two together really are something we
need to look at to make ourselves
more functional to new audiences.
>> Teach the people to work
together, that I think is not
so easy because you said, it's
more a matter of a frame mind,
a matter of how you think, how
you approach different problems.
The same question tells
different things
to different people
according to their background.
>> So we have bridges to build
as well as infrastructures under.
>> I think one of the
dangerous things here
when we start doing digital
humanities research is the
technology to some extent is
not really the problem anymore.
The problem is the
questions and the imaginations
of the people doing the work
and people asking the questions
so we've talked a number of
times about standards and one
of the biggest standards,
the ontological standards
to describe cultural heritage
information now is something called
the [inaudible].
Now the [inaudible] has been around
and devised for 20 odd years now
but they've just brought
out some new ones
so there's one called [inaudible]
which is all about modeling belief
so you can go through
the whole structure
of ontologically modeling how
much you believe something
and whether someone else
believes something else
and I think there is a
danger to some extent
of technological level gazing
in that you can spend years
doing technology research
because it's interesting
and the technology research
is really fun to do.
But, without the two
way conversation
between the people actually
exploring the data or wanting
to research the data that
other people have gathered,
we're missing the opportunity
and often it's people say well,
I don't really want to get
engaged with the digital bit
because I have no idea what
it is and it's complicated
and then you've got the digital
people who need to apply for a grant
and to apply for a grant
it's got to be new and novel
which means they keep pushing
the boundaries and you end
up with this bit where the
technology is going like this
and you end up with
a really sharp spike.
So, I think our difficulty
moving forward is making sure
that the developments
in the technology are actually
making people's lives easier
and making the jobs they need
to do easier and quicker.
>> Okay challenge.
>> Yes.
>> I will sort of build on what
Joe just said which is that for me,
I think it's extremely important to
recognize that we need to have tools
that are available to help people
do what they actually want and need
to do, not to say that you
close the door on the fact
that there are things that we
haven't even thought about yet.
And when Luca raises the question
of how do we create these tools,
I think that it's going to be very
important that the many databases
like for example, if one is looking
for data it's not very useful
to a broad audience
to absolutely have
to know exactly what
is this database
and then go there and search that.
You need to be able to find
it more at a Google-like way
where the search for
information doesn't require
that you specifically go to
one site and certainly I mean,
with Conservation Space that
information which is made accessible
to a broader audience, our hope
is that people use a Google search
with the right tools they can
actually find us and then you know,
the gallery for example
is the Official Archives
of the Crest Foundation and
all of that information,
which we're close to, will
be made fully accessible
to the whole broad
community out there
and it's not absolutely decided
but almost certainly it's going
to happen by putting that
into Conservation Space
but that will be available
to the public.
I think that people using their
normal search techniques like Google
or something like that
and then finding
out that there's this wonderful data
out there can really inspire people
to dream things we haven't
even thought of yet.
>> Well that sounds like
a very good moment to end.
I would like to thank all the
panelists and invite Fenella to come
to the podium for concluding
remarks.
[ Applause ]
>> This has got to be one
of the most unwieldy
microphones I've ever worked with.
So just a few things to put out
there to prime you for tomorrow
and make sure that
you're still all awake.
Just an overview that we've had a
really wonderful in depth overview
of the state of research
infrastructure initiatives,
we've looked at the challenges of
promoting these at a policy level
and also looked at the differences
in approaches between the European
and the US approach and the
different funding models and how
that ties into, sort of pushing us
in slightly different directions.
That, from the US side a number
of my colleagues and I have talked
about the focus on some sort of
consortium to provide a united front
in lieu of our Ministry of
Culture and what I very much
like from [inaudible], how the
new baseline funding in the US,
that we kind of are happy if
it's flat and it's not shrunk.
It's sad but it's real.
And how do we squeeze more
from the resources we have
for our collaborative efforts?
I think that's really what a lot of
us are saying that we're engaging
in some of the efforts and
if we can make better use
of those then we can really make
things go a little bit further.
What I did find very strong though
is that the underlying thread
in terms of the strength
of the collaborations is
the personal connections
and interactions and all of us
have found and have been motivated
to engage more effectively because
of strong personal interactions
and because we feel so
deeply about what we do
and so I think that's going
to help us all move forward
with the wonderful approach to
really sharing and being engaged
in what the field needs,
where the field needs to be.
So this heritage network of
experts and professionals linked
to the multidisciplinary fields
and colleagues outside is
really what we're trying
to pull together here.
And just as a final
point what I really,
really want is my own virtual
digital assistant [laughter].
So thank you all so much.
If you have any questions about
location [inaudible] at the back
and if any of you would like a
quick tour through our labs just
to see what we've got, we'd be
delighted to host that so again,
thank you to all of
the speakers today
and thank you all for
your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.